.
ANTHONY?
>> JAMIE YUCCAS IN MINNEAPOLIS.
THANK YOU, JAMIE.
>>> WE'RE JOINED BY CBS NEWS
LEGAL CONTRIBUTOR, THAT'S ALEXIS
HOAG, CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY AND
L
LECTURER AT LAW SCHOOL.
THE OPENING ARGUMENTS ARE SO
CRUCIAL THAT 80% OF JURORS HAVE
MADE UP THEIR MIND AFTER THE
OPENING ARGUMENTS.
IF THAT'S TRUE, HOW IMPORTANT
ARE THESE CLOSING ARGUMENTS
TODAY, NUMBER ONE, AND NUMBER
TWO, WHAT DOES EACH SIDE NEED TO
SHOW?
LET'S START WITH HOW CRUCIAL
THEY ARE TODAY.
>> THEY ARE CRUCIAL.
AS YOU SAY, A GOOD CLOSING
ARGUMENT WILL REINFORCE THE
OPENING STATEMENTS.
AND PARTIES CANNOT OVERPROMISE
AND THEN UNDERDELIVER.
IF THAT HAPPENS, IT'S HARDER FOR
THE JURORS TO SIDE WITH THEM.
SO WHAT WE CAN EXPECT FROM THE
STATE IS WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT A.G. BLACKWELL TOLD US FROM
THE BEGINNING THAT WE CAN
BELIEVE WHAT WE SEE WITH OUR
EYES.
HE WILL BE REVIEWING ALL OF THE
HAUNTING VIDEO EVIDENCE THAT WE
SAW THROUGHOUT THE TRIAL.
THIS INCLUDES THE MORE THAN A
DOZEN POLICE OFFICERS WHO
TESTIFIED THAT GEORGE FLOYD'S
MURDER WAS CAUSED BY DEREK
CHAUVIN.
WHEN WE HEARD FROM THE POLICE
OFFICER WHO SAID THAT CHAUVIN
DID NOT ADHERE TO POLICE
PROTOCOL, AND THAT HIS ACTIONS
WERE TOTALLY UNNECESSARY.
>> NOW THE DEFENSE ONLY NEEDS TO
CONVINCE ONE JUROR TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS NOT A GUILTY
VERDICT.
DOES THAT GIVE THEM AN
ADVANTAGE, DO YOU THINK?
>> IN SOME WAYS YES, IN OTHER
WAYS NOW.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THIS TRIAL.
AND AS I OPENED WITH, A.G. --
RATHER, NELSON, THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, HE REALLY DID
OVERPROMISE WHAT WE COULD HEAR.
HE SAID THAT WE COULD RELY ON
OUR COMMON SENSE, OUR LOGIC, AND
REASONABLE DOUBT AND REASON.
BUT FOLLOWING THAT GUIDANCE,
THAT COULD LEAD US TO A
CONV
CONVICTION.
HE HAS TO WALK BACK FROM THIS
OVERPROMISE THAT THE CROWD WAS
ANGRY AND CONTRIBUTED TO DEREK
CHAUVIN'S ACTIONS.
HE HAS TO WALK BACK TO THE FACT
THAT SUPPOSEDLY CHAUVIN ADHERED
TO MINNEAPOLIS POLICE DEPARTMENT
PROTOCOL.
THE STATE'S CASE WAS VERY STRONG
ON THESE ISSUES.
>> YEAH, THEY THREW A LOT AT THE
JURY IMPLYING THAT IT WAS DRUG
USE, HIS HEALTH CAONDITIONS,
CARBON MONOXIDE.
DEREK CHAUVIN OPTED NOT TO TAKE
THE STAND IN HIS OWN DEFENSE.
WILL THAT WORK AGAINST HIM, DO
YOU THINK?
>> THE JUDGE ADMONISHED JURORS
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THEY
CANNOT CONSIDER.
IT WILL BE ON THEIR MINDS, BUT
THEY HAVE TO SET IT ASIDE.
IN THIS CASE, IT'S AN ISSUE OF
WHO DID IT, INTENT TO KILL IS
NOT AT ISSUE.
AND SO I THINK THIS WAS REALLY
AN INSTANCE WHERE THE FACT THAT
CHAUVIN DIDN'T TESTIFY WON'T
REALLY WEIGH AS HEAVILY ON THESE
JURORS' MINDS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL FIND OUT LATER THIS
WEEK.
ALEXIS HOAG, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL BRING YOU LIVE COVERAGE
OF THE CLOSING ARGUMENTS IN THE
DEREK CHAUVIN TRIAL IN A CBS
SP